hello everybody thanks for having me
today
I'm here to give a brief talk about sort
of Shenzhen and sort of how you know
it's ecosystem has evolved over time and
into its own sort of style of innovation
its own self thinking in terms of design
and IP and and so forth so first thing
first I'm gonna start to talk a bit with
a kind of guided tour of Shenzhen to try
and introduce people to you what it's
about and what's made there how things
happen and then I'm going to pivot a bit
from there into talking about how
intellectual property plays into this
and how ideas are traded inside the
ecosystem so it sounds like some people
have yeah I have so familiar with the
Shenzhen but we'll get started for
everyone and what I call like a zoom in
to eruptions in so ideas are business
great series from the 1970s couple
powers of 10 where you start out from
like universe we zoom it easily jam it
into like a pro probably beat someone's
hand on the end of a good comic level
and so I'm going to start first kind of
like a 1x emissions in and and kind of
keep on zooming in until we end up with
street corners of the area and so oh
yeah one other no is before I get into
that sort of zooming in tour I want to
clarify when when I say to which enzyme
actually sort of referring to the whole
Pearl River Delta Area so a lot of
people have used Shenzhen sort of like
they may use San Francisco defer to
Silicon Valley which can refer to
anywhere from like you know Pleasanton
all the way up to Santa Rosa or
something like that so it's not when
people talk about Shenzhen sort of
colloquially it could be going to
someone don't want it could be going to
Guangzhou but the whole area itself is
actually quite large
and consists of about 40 million people
and has over pretty close to half half a
trillion dollars GT and and so yeah and
so the question is how did this area
essentially go from a fishing village to
attack power house in about 30 years
and so when actually when I first
started visiting Shenzhen about 10 years
ago I told my mom I was going to go
visit and she's actually Chinese descent
but has grown up in America for the last
50 years or something like that and and
she asked me like why would I go to the
place which is like like essentially a
slum and a fishing village because
that's what it was back in the 80s
around the time that she's last time she
visited the country and now you know
this picture here is like a actually
pretty common image of us sort of us
stall you can find almost along the
street side of people fixing iPhones and
so forth with some fairly advanced
equipment and techniques so sort of
starting a what exhume of Shenzhen and
ecosystem is sort of the stereotypes you
have about China right there you go
there to build stuff is this this
companies like Foxconn that have over
many employees and over one hundred
billion dollars in revenue they make
over 100 million major products per
month people are generally aware that
they're trying to serve a communist
country and that iPhones are made there
and then you start to end up with these
sort of interesting stories about like
both these products shown on the screen
here I made Chen Zhen so that the
product on the right is an iPhone 6 and
the product on the left is something
that looks like an iPhone 6 but it's
much smaller and it runs Android and
cost about 40 bucks
and then if you go around the ecosystem
you find that's actually more about just
iPhones and they're clones
you have you know this here's a picture
of sort of a typical vendors stall of
selling the local wares you can see from
the picture in the top left there
there's every single object in that case
there is capable placing a phone call so
these little sort of model card shape
phones phones in sort of these sort of
kid-friendly packages and so forth and
below I've shown you a picture of what
looks like an Apple watch except that
actually has the phone built into it so
it doesn't have to tether to a phone to
make a call they actually put the whole
base band into the watch itself and the
locals are very proud of that they're
like why why did the Apple build a phone
a watch that couldn't place calls
they're very confused about that so they
just put the phone into the watch and
then they have here on the right-hand
side a picture of a phone that's made to
look like a practice cigarettes for
whatever reason but you can get that
there - so then you zoom in a little
more in say okay well let's get in the
ground and concerns and I go to the
electronics district excuse a picture
actually from a funk buildings game area
and this looks like a pretty big urban
center and one might be time to think
this is like a financial district or
something like this but actually every
single building the see in this photo
here is devoted to the trade of
electronics and in the lower right hand
corner sort of a Google map see the area
it's about a mile on a side of high-rise
buildings chock full of electronics
stalls and vendors and designers to
trade this is sort of like the one of
the cores electronics ecosystem in
Shenzhen it's called a hot Shan Bay and
it's been around for a while and it
continues to be surprisingly at the core
of the ecosystem if you know how quickly
things change in China anything sort of
sticking around and in pole position for
more than a decade is pretty remarkable
if you walk into one of these buildings
this is a scene that you would see
it's kind of structured after a wet
market like a butcher's market or
something like this where you have a
bunch of small stalls that about maybe
10 feet long that contain essentially
one type of one style of electronics so
you can walk up to a stall and I'll have
a pressure cells LEDs another style of
cell cases for computers another stall
will sell just screws of some type of
other one will specialize the resistors
we pass this and you can walk around in
these areas and you know source
different types of components this is a
at a hundred thousand zoom this is what
it looks like inside one of these stalls
so two on the Left I don't know how
people are with how components are
traded but the round things you see in
the window what I call tape and reels of
capacitors this one specializes
primarily in capacitors and each of
those reels contains ten thousand
capacitors and each of those boxes
contain about ten reels so you're
looking at millions of capacitors right
now sitting inside of a store down which
you can just walk up to you with a few
bucks and buy one of these and then walk
to your production line and go to mass
production so it's a very urban
encounter method for buying production
quantities of components and on the
right hand side is a picture of some
chips they just have sitting on trays
and is range amps I went around once you
sort of looked a little more carefully
at the part numbers and realize that the
inventory that they had on hand in some
of these stalls were bigger than the
inventory they had online at places like
the Jackie O mouth so if you're familiar
with some of the distributors so the
amount of capability to exist in this
market is pretty remarkable
here's another image of like what one
does stalls like this they tend to be
family affairs they're run by your mama
pops and a lot of people don't
necessarily have a technical background
but the more traders all from the same
village
a lot of them are from the same village
in China so to speak speak a particular
dialect and if you have tried to learn
the language of the market you'll find
actually they use different terms for
the electronic components to the
academics would so if you were to go to
Chinese Academy of Sciences and learn
what a transistor is you went to the
marketing try to buy it one of those
they look at you funny these a much
simpler description of transistors are
called a 3-legged tube for example as
opposed to a metal oxide semiconductor
field effect transistor and in the lower
right hand corner is a picture like the
hustle-bustle of the market in this they
just load up toys with components and
you just hand pushing around the market
and and going to production with them so
taking another zoom in on the ecosystem
one will and you look around just in the
streets won't start to notice an
interesting phenomenon you see people
just standing around taking apart mobile
phones in the street the picture on the
left is a outside of an apartment
complex web state in the morning you'd
see people sort of just squatting over
piles of scrap phones and on the right
hand side is a picture of a typical sort
of phone strap vendor you just sort of
set up outside some cards put a little
sign down as a couple burlap sacks and
instead processing through phones that
people want to come up and buy parts
from or or you know try to get him to
buy some of their parts they could do
that this is another picture here where
you can see just an enormous number of
phones amountof kind of e-waste so to
speak and people i've just walked up to
it and started chucking out valuable
components from these phones and the
interesting part is if you just look
towards the back there you can see those
kind of TLC to the guy of the city
that's actually like a little like food
stall behind there and to the left you
can also see there's another just a hint
of another fruit stall so they actually
the broader context of this that this is
happening on so the footsteps to
restaurant area so to speak so it's a
very casual thing that happen there it's
not it's not like this happens in one
specific area people just sort of get
together and and at certain times of the
day waste will show up and people will
start pulling components out and doing
what they're right it's sort of
interesting question
and so I've looked at terms ecosystem to
the top to the bottom and try to figure
out like you know how how does this come
about and so train this picture sort of
upside down and figuring out how we got
to where we are today we can take a look
at sort of the numbers that I think they
have gotten us to the point where we are
in China from the trickle-down sort of
standpoint but China starts with about a
billion people in the 80s and at that
age big companies like Foxconn and then
Holloway and so forth invest a bunch of
money particularly in the border town
around Hong Kong the sort of higher tens
of millions of some believers and so
this sort of leads to a dashboard medium
to small size factories so you have like
these large what I call sort of flagship
factories but every single flagship
Factory needs to have a set of subsets
of factories and feeding components or
that even just maintain the machinery
inside these factories like you know if
you go if you look at a modern factory
day they may have like a thousand CNCs
on the inside that in itself is enough
to sort spawn an industry that maintains
those CMC's that's then and that sort of
diaspora meaning the small factories
happen in the 90s about a decade later
those assembly laborers make about one
percent of those people sort of
eventually figure enough from having
done things to sort of become a
technician engineer so they can repair
things or you can be somebody to
experience based engineering of new
products and around that point in time I
run the 2000 call the rise the Shan Zhai
so this is where technicians and
years I think it's smart enough inside
the factories to realize that the bosses
are making bad decisions and so you have
a bunch of people who work for like
Motorola and Nokia at the time hmm being
sort have risen up through the ranks and
weren't from the Western design team
side but were local people who said you
guys are stupid you're building phones
the wrong way we're going to quit and
we're going to make our own phones the
way we want to see the phones being made
and so this is where you start to see
the rise of the copycats and they're so
jumping out and building phones that
much much less sort of labor and effort
and cost than what the larger brands are
able to do and and so you know you have
like sort of like um you know at this
point thousands of managers designers
who have gone out and decided to start
their own little sort of sounds I shop
this is in the around the 2000s and all
of these thousands of managers and
designers who are building phones we've
now got about you know ten or so major
new tech corporations which are started
here about and sort of feel the
influence of out here United States so
we hear the words you know the brands of
shell me who has served Shen's I read
spies now a major player in the cell
phone space 10-cent Taliban Alibaba and
so forth who have served risen out of
this sort of trickle down to the bomb up
innovation that has has emerged from be
efficient an ecosystem an 18-point think
that that parallels this is how the
supply chain and capital equipment has
evolved along with it so on the left
here you can see sort of a parallel sort
rickle down chart for how the equipment
moves through the ecosystem so some
decades ago some will invest a million
dollars to buy steel via pick-and-place
a line and so the picture on the right
here is actually something I just shot
from the image of a well you know all of
the highways this is a whole picking
place line that's been loaded onto the
back of the
truck is in someone's trade entered and
in capacitor facility but it's done it's
done in it you can be interesting part
but it's done in such a haphazard way
they're just sort of put danger tape
over the thing and strapped it down and
just shipping it off and and in your
back when this language new in and of
cost hundred thousand dollars there's no
way you have shifted around but clearly
today they're just they're just learning
on the back of truck and sending around
and so what happens is that them some
decades ago someone invested a million
dollars into coplann assembly equipment
after about three three or four five
years or so the equipment's depreciated
like you've written it off you build a
whole bunch of phones with it and to
stay competitive you have to buy a new
million dollar line you don't take the
old line and throw it away you soft
someone else for a tenth of what you
bought for yourself as scrap four
hundred thousand dollars
except that scrap doesn't sit idle
someone really takes it they'll use it
for ten years to build something that's
not a cellphone but maybe they'll build
some other you know consumer product
like a router or something like that
that's not as competitive but still
demanding for about ten years and after
about ten years or using that there's I
saw that for scrap for about 10% we got
four so they'll sell the million dollar
line for ten thousand dollars and then
this this this line which is a robot so
it doesn't forget it doesn't really go
bad it still has the same precision is
it does it sold for $10,000 to these
small factories and it has the
capability to build mobile phones but
the capital require me to buy the
equipment to build a mobile phones has
now gone to just a fraction pennies on
the dollar of what used to cost back in
the original I'm line is originally
purchased so what you have is a lot of X
capability for buildings Capri high-end
gear in the ecosystem for cheek because
of the trickle down supply chain that's
paralleled the truth about innovation
and this leads us to sort of a sort of
an explanation of partial exploration at
least what we're seeing going on the
streets of this recycling is you have
like this sort of parallel around the
parts in the recycling business
that in going on in the ecosystem so if
you look at this chart here we have for
example someone building million-plus
unit bills and what you have when you're
going to go and build for example like
an iPhone or any mobile phone is that
you have like all the hot dogs and buns
problem so if you want to build or see
if you want to have a barbecue and you
go up you buy hot dogs here by buns find
hot dogs come in packs of eight can buns
come in packs of 10 so when the barbecue
is over you're going to have either some
hot dogs leftover it's a bun dressed
over a day I don't you know if you're if
you're not throwing them away
you're making croutons or whatever it is
out of the buns same things have happens
when you have these large builds is that
you can't really line up your inventory
to be exactly on as much you need for
every single part by the end of the bill
and plus when the demand tapers off a
lot of times you have a bit of inventory
back that for the pipe anyways and so
what happens is like we have fractions
of a percent of the million-plus you to
build are being liquidated typically at
about ten cents on the dollar but the
qualities at which these sort of builds
happening even that small fraction turns
into about ten thousand or so of some
pretty interesting components and so the
right-hand path is a sort of like sort
of more legitimate Greenmarket method of
dealing with this word you have
advocators which will take scrap and
excess from various different
manufacturers that aggregate we package
and test it tell it
50 times original price of the commodity
in the inside the the left-hand path is
that you know phones actually go and get
used by users for a while we turn to
e-waste and then they get recycled and
they also enter the grain market for
recycling and so this gets us on to sort
of the subject of of faking and sort of
what it means to be recycling and so to
try and explain the situation a little
bit more clearly on the left-hand side
here
see what people would normally I guess
you're on the outside say hey someone's
faking an iPhone right because you can
see what on the outset looks a bit like
an iPhone but it's clearly not an iPhone
now the thing is the ancient part is
that to build that stay on the left the
effort levels are actually very
difficult but detecting it as a fake is
very easy so actually this is not the
predominant problem that you have to
deal with an ecosystem in terms of face
what you have to deal with more
typically in the ecosystem is what
happens on the right hand side so here
is a picture about FPGA chip made by
Xilinx and the only way you can tell
that this is a fake is that on the this
little white rectangle in on this on
these sort of the laser etched part
numbers on the other chip and oh where
the rectangle ends if someone's gone in
with the laser cutter and they've
actually etched off the words es that
used to exist on there and es stands for
engineering samples so someone has gone
and they've taken parts that were meant
to be scrapped from a preliminary
production run the laser laser that's
off the markings for and they've sold it
into the supply chain as brand new parts
and so the effort level for creating
this sort of fake so to speak is
extremely easy right you didn't have to
have an engineering degree and have put
me on these circuit boards you just have
to know that someone's throwing away a
bunch of parts that are mostly zobelle
and detecting that is actually extremely
difficult you have to be trained to read
the part numbers understand what they
are and and in fact in this case we only
caucus because we're doing a JTAG
silicon ID verification of other parts
before we program them on it on the
production line and so in general the
most notorious space actually people
going through and employing the imaging
effort to sort of copy what people say
you know apples innovation or Google's
innovation out there a lot of them are
things a much simpler explanations like
for example go shifts a go shift is when
we do a force shift at the factory
so during the time whenever I'm supposed
to lead they shut down the factory the
supervisors stay around and they run it
for another shift so to take excess
material or to take material that once
I'm scheduled to be there we run on
exactly the production hardware with
exactly the perfect production tests we
cranked out our next to run and in that
case there the question is is that a
favor is that legitimate well the brand
would say it's a fake because they
didn't get the margin of selling as a
brand because every month they should
have done something at the very back end
to be able to keep all the margin for
themselves but from the user standpoint
this is um you know it's virtually the
same goods because it comes off the same
lines at the same technicians a lot of
the things are also refurbished parts
remark parts there's a lot of formative
fraud that happens and a lot of
improperly destroyed production defects
so the picture here you see is a stall
in sort of the markets that sell that
specializes in selling blank iPhone
motherboards so all these sort of black
flat things you see their iPhone
motherboards have had no components
attached so they're actually all
motherboards that were supposed to have
been ground up and thrown away because
they had one or more too many small
defects in them but people actually buy
these and they use them to build you
know you know fake iPhones from scratch
from others scrap parts that you see on
the market so one may wonder then like
what is the financial incentive for
people to go through and dig through
these you know phones on the sidewalk
and very very quickly you can sort of
see like the across the bottom the more
complete picture of what happens is
people who would be parts of the phones
on the left you have technicians in the
middle who are removing components from
the phones in the in the middle and on
the right-hand side you can see the
parts sort of refurbished in and
polished off and being sold as new in
these little actually little sauce trays
moment you get like you know soy sauce
in them in a restaurant but they just
put chips in them instead and so the
value of the parts is new on the tray on
the right-hand side maybe about $10 a
component those are flash memory chips
and when you walk into these stalls that
actually tell you this pipes have been
recycled we'll sell them to you at half
at half off
I dunno try they'll try to sell them to
you as new they just be like easy easy
walking is when it starts let's say
would you like the d12 would you like to
recycle words so they're very upfront
about it at least at that point in the
supply chain the key thing is has the
cost of goods for this part to zero like
these people we were going through a
ways to point them out and a minimum
wage worker in the area may be paid
about a thousand maybe per month about
$160 and the years has been a mage
workers on the factory line so we
trained them actually to pull parts off
of boards and this is a legitimate
operation that happened so I was in the
factory that made graphics cards and I
was watching them take graphics cards in
past tests and they had a labor they're
working with a hot-air gun like the
incresing that middles shot they're
pulling off the memory chips rebounding
them and send them back into the
production line for yeast and other
cards either ones add impact test and so
this person is being paid $160 per hour
is recovering about once every four or
five minutes about five dollars worth of
parts for the factory for the creating
immense amount of value for the factory
but being paid almost nothing in terms
of animal age what happens is some of
these workers figure out that they're
making a lot of value for the factory
but not realizing any of it themselves
so they go out and they start figuring
out how to pull parts off of phones and
they're producing dishes like the one
below which is about two thousand
dollars what the parts in that and that
dish there alone and they can sort of
earn a u.s. wage credit equivalent of
some unique element of wage about a two
thousand dollar a year salary
effectively by sort of just instead of
working for the factory at minimum wage
going out finding a waste and
refurbishing recycling them and turning
them into resellable parts so that's
that explains at least one bit why you
see people in this ecosystem all over
the place just in the street digging
stuff out of like phones crawling them
out and a lot of people sitting around
installs pulling parts off of
motherboards
to inject the back into spriting but the
thing is is like the pipes themselves
are only semi useful how do they go from
these parts into normal phone lines
there's more required to that than a
technician who is trained in the factory
and how use a soldering iron and how to
reball BGA's and so you're going to need
some amount of design IP to to take
these parts to put them into phones and
here that is actually a picture that
pulled out of one of the local documents
again like in some explaining all the
parts of a phone and and so and so forth
what's required to build it and there's
a system that I've been trying to sort
of attach together there about how they
share IP locally it's not really open
source I call it I give a different name
I call it going high and the reason I do
that is because open source itself
actually has a Chinese translation and
it refers to the same legal concept of
open source the United States so I use a
different Chinese word to refer to it so
we don't confuse gong kind with proper
open source which has been properly
licensed and is totally legal from the
Western standpoint and this sort of gunk
I system has evolved in China in it with
an absence of Western influence but it
has a similar sort of ability to enable
access with a different legal construct
it is a lot of innovators to rip mix and
burn in hardware and it's been
fine-tuned over a long time from
ecosystem the values product over patent
but the question is sort of how does it
have this whole ecosystem come about
where people are sharing IP and and so
and so forth Yogi's you know as as
people from the West
well know your patents are an important
part of incentivizing people to take a
risk to go ahead and innovate and the
reason you see maybe see this light here
okay right so I have a slide QB go
off by one and and so to review sort of
what the Western social IT bargain is is
that sort of the United States
you know Constitution sort of including
this across that gave Congress the power
to promote progress of science and
useful arts by allowing them to secure
for a limited period of time the
exclusive right to respective writings
and discoveries and so the idea is that
you have a bargain where people would be
given a material reward for taking risk
to come up with ideas and giving them in
a term of monopoly right so if you go
ahead and either invest time and effort
to try and invent something you may get
a patent or copyright on the idea and
that would allow you to monetize that to
sort of make up for the risks that you
taken to to best to come up with the
idea on the other hand the idea behind
patents in itself is say you publish the
idea so other people can learn from it
that's the whole idea of a patent system
and that one is one of the bars of game
patents that you have to include enough
with two independent that some expense
the art can reproduce the patent itself
so it's sort of an idea of sharing ideas
promote code source innovation the
problem with the the US patent system is
at kuang quote limited times is an
eternity in terms of technology so it's
a twenty year
patent term until you put that in
perspective you know the 80 88 when is
excuse in 1979 ran at five megahertz and
twenty years later the painting three
copper mine or twenty eight hundred
megahertz so technologies was way too
fast for patents to be effectively open
sourcing ideas and we should you seem
into the ecosystem many of the promise
that their copyrights are as many people
aware as effectively like 120 years the
lifetime effectively so it's not like
you know people aren't able to even own
their childhood at this point in time
people who grew up to Star Wars will
never be able to you know remix that
into their own fanfiction without having
to pay I guess now gives me rights to
those
characters the thing is that you know
motivations have changed and so it's not
so much about always money at this point
in time you know open source
western-style open source has evolved
over people who don't necessarily want
to have money as the motivator for them
to create the ideas but they may want
for example public recognition or they
want a legacy or curiosity to have some
altruism so open source was born of
closed source law where people go ahead
and say okay I'm going to use the
license rights I have to this to just at
least protect myself from liability and
gain public recognition while going has
improving the sharing of crowdsource
ideas the problem is is that even open
source from the Western standpoint has a
very heavy legal burden this is a sort
of one of those funny points where we
saw sort of the open source initiative
see the open source hybrid initiative
over the logo looking too similar to
their logo and a lot of the lawyers that
were sort of involved in this we're
saying well but we have to suit each
other over this because if you don't try
to protect your trademark then the trade
web uses it's sort of validity in the in
the Western theory of law and so it's
not like this sort of thing where open
source in the Western ecosystem just
happens you don't have to spend a lot of
money doing it the point of this is that
like if you want to exercise open source
in the Western standpoint there is still
a very resource-intensive
activity at the end of the day and so
what's the sort of impact that we see of
the sort of legal burden at least from
the experience standpoint and so this is
a interesting kind of compare and
contrast of gunk I versus open where on
the left-hand side I show a picture of a
typical motherboard which is sort of a
fruit of the shared by ecosystem on the
right hand side I show in a real mother
bullet which is sort of the fruit of the
open hardware ecosystem and so the open
hardware ecosystem has has yielded us a
$29
circuit board which consists of a 60
megahertz
cpu with 2.5 km a USB co interface and
voltage regulator and that would be sort
of considered a very standard in the
open source world on the left hand side
from the gumline world this eco system
of sharing IP in China has yield us for
260 mega Hertz turns to the CPU at 8
megabytes to integrated RAM a quad-band
gsm modem bluetooth OLED mp3 player can
probably battery and the whole things
available for $12 and this is this sort
of compare and contrast sort of gives an
I think that the idea of maybe what
might be possible if one reduces the
legal burden of sharing IP it allows
people so just start remixes and
creating products based on a much looser
IP measurement but then the question is
is like in a horoscope I survive
according to basic Western IP theory the
bargain is broken if people are able to
sort of share IP so quickly innovators
investors have no motive to take a risk
but the experience is showing that you
know sir business is booming from these
companies linking of Xiaomi which got a
four billion valuation or a mediatek do
is you know make hundreds of millions of
smartphone chips and that was back in
2012 so the short answer is that you
know gonca itself is a galapagos it sort
of grew up in ecosystem to a clean sheet
without any influence from the Western
ecosystem and it sort of figured out its
own sets of cultural morals and rules
and principles and and so sort of the
the image I like to sort of portray this
is that on the left hand side here you
have a changing face sorry but this like
you serve shows the changing face of
innovation and so on the left here you
show what what I like to see is sort of
like a classic view of what Western IP
this is a picture that was drawn you
know many many years ago and it shows
sort of like the lone inventor like
little gray beard sort of in front of
this glowing flask of phosphorus and
it's the point of revelation of the
alchemists in the background the others
a couple of younger people who might be
doing something but really the whole
idea is that
innovation is about sort of celebrating
this one lone hero and they continue to
sort of promulgate this idea in pop
culture so you have the idea of er Tony
Stark and Iron Man who is like the sort
of lone innovator who works alone
doesn't have any help any service
associated Jarvis built be this
wonderful idea and he was out drinking
comes back and this robot suit appears
out of nowhere right you know so the
lone inventor is responsible for
building all these things on the right
hand side is sort of more the face of
trans innovation this is actually a map
of the Internet where you can't really
point to a particular person who has
innovated but still it's an emergent
property of a very connected ecosystem
so the the core point I think about sort
of old versus new styles of innovations
that the older style innovation patents
and copyrights is all about attribution
so we can go back through the archives
to see in 1970 1917 a guy named G Sun
back was granted patent 1 million - 2 9
2881 for the zipper and today on the
right hand side we in contrast to that
we share for example cat memes a lot of
pictures which are you know this is just
a clip from Google image search and the
interesting point about this is that
every single one of those photographs
actually have a copyright to them the
person who took this photographs
technically have the exclusive right to
the use of those pictures of those cats
but no one asks for example who took a
picture of those cats so about which one
got the most clever caption and who's
traded it most and this anyone who's had
to give talks and have to prove that
they have the right to use all their
sort of pictures will encounter the
trouble of trying to attribute a meme
you want to go ahead and use a cat main
photo inside a picture you want to say
hey here's my here's my disclosure and
authorization to use these go find that
they can't find anyone you know because
they can never find the original author
who took a lot of these very popular
meme photos
but you know we've accepted this in the
Western ecosystem that you know virality
is important and sort of look the other
way when it comes to sort of copyrights
or memes
so what you have here is you have sort
of like a diversion evolution you have a
IP concept the same class of sort of
species but they have different
conditions so like on the left you have
a mammal which is securely way on the
right you have a mammal which is a bat
they're both you know biologically
related to each other but they have a
different you know serve characteristics
because of the environment in which they
grew up in and so IP in China in
particular was a sort of factory culture
meeting the internet and so practically
in China itself and sort of was the idea
of promoting you know sort of workers
over all else here as you know China has
a sort of a communist past this is a
comics present but you know a much more
hardcore communist crafts packing days
when they're sort of propaganda photos
where they show people you know working
together to build a great future of
China
you know constructing a locomotive and
so forth and so they would actually sort
of celebrate the workers and the people
who would build things the interesting
thing is that a lot of people feel that
they can just sort of start a factory
now right so factories are cheap and at
the other day everyone owns a factory in
China so there's a picture of a very
small facility that I worked with at one
point in time to build some plastic
inserts for a book this book both of men
you see the picture there are factory
owners a young guy on the Left owns a
printing factory builder guy in the
middle as a factory of doing inserts for
printed books and you know it's kind of
in a garage literal sort of garage
startup thing where you sort of bought
some equipment and he's and he's able to
stamp out the inserts for books the
result of of this sort of factory
culture is that you have what I call
capability over inventory so if you were
to
go for example to Best Buy and buy a USB
cable and you want a USB cable is
exactly 1.8 meters long because that's
the distance from your keyboard to your
computer and you don't want to have an
extra coil cable and you go to the I say
hire like at one point via USB cable the
blue shirt man would look at you and be
like well you have 1.5 meter cables and
two meeting tables why don't you take
the 2 meter cable and just coil the
extra point 2 meters right leave out the
site so no no I really want a 1.8 Beauty
USB cable he would look at you funny and
be like what's wrong with you just by
our inventory like we imported oil and
stuff from China for you really at 1.5
and T however if you go to China and you
meet someone who has a factory who goes
cables they have you know raw wire and
they have connector ends and they have
an over molding machine that's what the
machine there in the middle is they say
hello I would like to have a 1.8 liter
USB cable the guy would be like ok
they'll walk up the machine
darling 1.8 meters and out kachunk which
would be 1 meter cable so in an
ecosystem where people have factories
they're not trying to sell you a
particular say they're not trying to
sell you a certain length of cable you
can actually make your cable through to
the size that you want and remarkably
small quantities if you have to know the
person who owns the machine and run the
cables for you and so what you have at
their day in this ecosystem is this
massive set of factories and sub
suppliers which all come together
through the sort of centralized market
to go ahead and bring consumers of
products to consumers and as an evidence
of this is that one of the complaints
that happen when the maker faire went to
Shenzhen is that look more like a trade
show and less show and tell and that's
natural when you have us you know
basically everyone can own a factory
even the makers own we had sort of
full-on factories with a little bit of
funny is how you end up looking it but
what looks more like a CES rather than
sort of a maker faire at the end of the
day so that's that's factory culture in
China let's talk a little about sort of
the Internet in China so this is again
this is the sort of a map of the
internet from from a bit
way back content is pretty openly shared
in China so here's a screenshot of a
website in China called dy/dt 8 it
roughly translates to booby heaven and
you can see that you know you can
download blu-ray discs
copies rips of you know Finding Nemo the
line Walker Chinese dramas also stuff
going on between and 5 now after all
available you just sort of click on it
and download it for free so know as
people are well aware there's a lot of
sort of open content sharing in China
perhaps not always neatly the
interesting part is that for technology
they have analogous websites so there's
a website here called fight to our decom
where people can go ahead and ask
questions and download you know sort of
mobile phone schematics and ask advice
about things so the answer is there's a
thread here about everything you want to
know about the new apple chips new a10
chip and so forth and there's people
asking questions about electromagnetic
shielding and so and so forth and so if
you were to going to on these websites
you can go ahead and poke around and
effectively download a phone the plans
for phones these are so some of the
files that I got off of a site like this
you can get the full data sheet for the
mediatek sort of chip that cheese on the
inside and of course it's fully covered
with watermarks tell you that this is
like confidential and not for lease and
someone else's IP but people just
download and share it and I was able to
for example download not just the what I
call the Gerber files which was used to
make the circuit board for the actual
design source the or CAD board files for
the for the for the for the phone so I
can go ahead and take a phone have a
core IP and then modify it say change
the shape of it to fit inside a
different case very easily and you're
able to get the editable live schematics
out of an ecosystem like this so the net
result of having sort of a factory
culture meet this sort of rampant
sharing style internet in China is
essentially you go from
shirring cat memes sharing phone meets
at the other day though in the u.s. that
meal did sort of our reality ecosystem
has gone from yet the pinnacle of it is
sort of caps with clever captions on it
and in China the pinnacles of reality
and sharing there is people rhythmic
bernhard we're creating phones of all
different types unpacking that ecosystem
a little bit instead of you know if you
to look and sort of put labels on what
all these different factories are in
ecosystems you have people who will
specialize in very specific areas such
as industrial design or plastics tooling
components firmware circuit boards and
system integrators and the role of
sharing in a network like that is that
you have a high you have so many
different people who can give you for
example components that in order to be
discovered um you know sorry in order to
have sales you can discovered so one of
the big sort of barriers to becoming
successful and having your stuff out
there isn't so much producing a more
acquiring the goods it's being
discovered about it so a lot of times
for example component vendors like
mediatek will find ways to creatively
leak here their plans on to the internet
so people can discover it and then that
would be picked up by a PCB a
manufacturer who had been depicted by a
system integrator all these people
progressively leaking their levels of IP
on to the internet so that it can be
discovered trying it into the final
system that ultimately gets into
consumers hands and this is one of those
sort of leakage of things that you know
both the manufacturers and the designers
and the any end the system agrees are
complicit on but the ecosystem works out
reasonably well because at the end of
the day when you go ahead and share the
IP because i I P for a product you also
have to buy the chip at the end of the
day it's not like quite like sharing a
movie where the movie itself is the
product and you're actually just taking
the product of a studio and watching and
not getting any money sharing the design
IP for chip in itself requires you to
buy that chip to do like that if you
like what you see in the manual you're
going to eventually do a transaction
that benefits the
company that releases the manual and so
at the end of day what you find is that
embodiment really matters
here's another sort of classic case of
sort of patent versus product on the
left hand side here is dependent for the
two-wheel hoverboard which you may have
heard about those would be crazy and
that the United States a couple years
ago and this is the patent that was
filed by an inventor named chin and the
patents dated May 27 2014 yos filed feb
11 2013 and Tuesday the person who filed
the patent is still contemplating you
know how to monetize is patently good
through licensing litigation and body
make and so and so forth at the same
time that that patent was filed the
Chinese ecosystem was cranking out you
know electric bikes single wheeled
unicycles electric bicycles and scooters
and so and so forth so they're already
doing things which are on its face
relatively similar to the two-wheel
hoverboard right so they already
embodied these things these are prior
art in the knowledge an existing
ecosystem
interesting part is that these aren't
patents that they have these are actual
factories cranking all these items so
when the two-wheel hoverboard was first
kind of burst on preceding story I heard
a say you know Justin Bieber was seen
rolling onto a stage with it and the man
sort of exploded for these things
there was a already a huge
infrastructure of people who was able to
build all the components that went into
your hoverboard people who could build
the high torque low rpm motors people
who can build like the cases nebuilder
power trains and the battery systems
that go into these and so to go ahead
and actually go from what they were
building today the two-level though is a
very small leap for them and so they're
able to quickly embody the idea just
from seeing it on a picture on the
screen they didn't even have to read the
pattern at the other day so you know
there's a there's a question here it's
like you know we have ecosystem like
this which one it's more valuable is it
is a product source of pipes
so generally speaking in this ecosystem
people will instead of spending money on
the legal leaves to go ahead and protect
their intellectual property they're
rather spend money to go ahead and build
a product get it out there and sort of
trade them very rapidly don't you end up
with that any day sort of reinforcement
cycle you have people who are rapidly
embodying products who are getting money
for investing in factories creating
capability and then going ahead and
releasing a product into the into the
ecosystem very quickly and so the this
has sort of led to an emergency sort of
innovation so you go from sort of funky
little phones like the one on the left
here which is a phone made for kids to
sort of like the Shelbys of the world
who are able to build phones that hold
their own against Samsung's and Sony's
and HTC's to now what we have is like
literal people who are promoting open
platform to make the system so you can
see this slightly of all a paywall
all are clearly swords kite kite func
pink eye which means literally an open
platform for for financial transactions
and Ali pay in 2014 handled 778 billion
dollars of transactions whereas Apple
pay in 2050 has only managed to cover 11
billion dollars in transactions so you
have a sort of like emergent innovation
rapid adoption that's happening in the
ecosystem because of the sort of the low
barrier to sort of training and sharing
IP at the end of the day and so again
what you have is sort of different
conditions
give these different species but both
are mammals
you have IP from the West and also IP in
the East both or have their sort of quid
pro quo in the method of sharing about
them but you know IP in the West sort of
is designed to encourage a high risk
basic research so if you're going to do
things like the amiga physics or so drug
discovery that sort of thing it's a very
good EP expense for that you can have
predictable defensible learning models
anyhow I'm a very methodical innovation
so you have main eventers people whose
names are attached they must be attached
to practice if you can't file a patent
on behalf of an open English system we
do if you're an open source you just
want to say I want to protect this idea
controls taking it you can't be like I
file us on behalf of community you have
to put your name on the pattern and then
license it's that creating in comparison
Chinese style innovation that's reason
there is an agile robust network that
handles a systemic complexity very well
so if you want to build the complex
products that have a lot of different
parts you have a very deep ecosystem you
can pull from of some vendors to do sort
of having to invest and build all that
from scratch the problem is that you
have a pretty constant churn that's
fairly competitive you have to sort of
you know continue to invest into
ecosystem interview factory to go ahead
and stay competitive and at the end of
day which you have this innovation is
more of an emergent property of that
work you don't you don't have named
inventors but rather you have a whole
network itself creating an innovation
ecosystem so the opportunity identity
that I feel is sort of you know how do
you sort of blend take the best of both
worlds in this life what I've been doing
for the last few years and trying to see
how how do i conness that news ecosystem
of innovators and sort of try to try to
put a capstone on top of that and figure
out how to you know green you know so
products to consumers that extremely
you're sort of a disruptive price points
and sort of disruptive amounts of sort
of upfront costs to getting those
products into the ecosystem and so
that's my that's my talk I guess I'll
take open the forward to questions
[Applause]
microphone um we have a question so if
you okay you said you wanted to do a
capstone on top of it but these standard
Western responses but you'll get 2% of
the market and Amazon will be flooded
with clones in 48 hours
so it's correct so what do you do slava
Justin Bieber's sticker on it no no so
so part of the part of the idea behind
this is that the idea is not to capstone
it as being a brand in the sense that
I'm just sort of taking another
factory's product and selling on the
market that's that's the way you end up
with like you know 98% of the stuff on
Amazon being clones you actually need to
you actually need to be a little closer
to the ecosystem you don't just caption
up I literally created layer paint on it
you cap started by by being in sort of
an affix Factory in the ecosystem and so
for example one of the things I try to
focus on is process innovation in an
actual facility in China I go into a
factory in China I take a process they
have and I modify it in a way that's not
obvious to produce something that people
haven't seen before a different finish a
different flexibility a different
material system altogether and so if
another if someone were to another
factory would see it they would actually
have to think pretty hard you know how
do I do the sale to prom with the
huggable it was that all the separate
products were were put were available
like there wasn't any almost there's
almost zero modification required in a
standard process to build the hoverboard
it was just a retaking of Lego park so
to speak and so he is you want to go
ahead and you want to leverage the
pieces you have in transit but put them
together in a way that's not obvious
that is that that requires someone to do
a bit of hard on indeed to try and
create the product that you create
so that changes the threshold from 48
hours to eight months yeah I would say
like like one of the products I recently
introduced and being flexible circuits
that have a sticker backing on them and
I took us about like a - six to eight
months to sort of develop that process
in China with a factory and and we've
had numerous actually attempts of people
from actually the United States and
other people print some time trying to
copy us but no one's been able to figure
out the process that we have and
essentially trades to get process that
we do with one one vendor in China cool
um does this work for or sort of
complement okay I'm going to trigger the
question while Alan Asturias so it is
there a qualitative difference in the
kind of innovation you get from these
two styles seems like there would be yes
there is a difference in in the types of
innovation that you get out of it like
like you do get you know from the
Western ecosystem like I said here you
attend you get a little more high risk
basic research you can you get some very
clever things out of the Western
ecosystem but a lot of times we also get
you know in here in terms of what you
need to hammer nails you need a hammer
you don't necessarily need you know a
robotic system that can go ahead and
place nails in with a controlled force
profile all the time and so you tend to
get more hammers out of the Chinese
ecosystem and you tend to get more
sophisticated you know how you know very
precise things on the western ecosystem
but one of the other quality of things
you see that's different though is that
for example out of the trays ecosystem
you can get mobile phones well as the
Western ecosystem has failed by and
large at the startup level to create
phones like Apple has created phones
because they have
huge amount of money to invest create a
vertical ecosystem of suppliers to sort
of go feed into their phones but I've
seen people I had a picture I think up
here on the upper left-hand corner here
this is a it looks a little campy but
it's a phone made for kids to call home
but they don't the pants don't want kids
to be distracting class texting so you
see only has like five buttons on it we
pre-assigned the numbers using like a
little USB UI and then the kids can pick
in home there's actually been I did a
little research on this nervous there
was a couple stars United States that
raised five to ten million dollars to
try and build something exactly like
this and they all fail because you know
I peaked the constraints it couldn't get
the you know that can be the license for
the spectrum have good carry those her
stuff and there's like a you know a
dozen of these phones in the market in
China and I you know the rumor has it
they cost about twenty five to fifty
thousand dollars to crank out this
particular model and sewing from the
Chinese ideal systemic complexity so
there's reason why they able crank the
cell for so little is that there's these
other vendors who have four billion the
base bands other vendors been from other
business brilliant plastics and so
system innovator only has to spend a
smaller money to create what would be a
substantial complex product in the
United States I was thinking more in
terms of things that need a whole
ecosystem so for example the iPod needed
iTunes Nespresso needs the whole supply
chain of the pods and the coffee and the
quality management that seems to be
quite different in quality qualitatively
from the kind of innovation you've been
talking about in Shenzhen that's an
interesting question you are starting to
see more of the sort of largest so you
have a consumable plus a good thing
starting to occur so the bigger brands
like Xiaomi and Alibaba are starting to
create these types of systems so you
know a leap a itself at you know has
created this ecosystem that we can you
have to have the phones
you have to have the payment
infrastructure you have to have the the
QR code readers and so on and so forth
and they're doing sonar so many billion
dollars of business they have a cupboard
equivalent there they have an Amazon
equivalent there you know I don't think
there's for example as much of a market
for an espresso these the Chinese people
just wouldn't pay two dollars for a cup
of coffee when they can pay much much
less for you know a coffee to other
other mechanisms but Nespresso has done
a really good job of mug being a product
and making people you know feel it's
worth those little capsules at the end
of the day by thinking I was trying to
see a bit of this as ecosystem matures
and grows up I think
but those models fitting your model of
the Shenzhen very loose man everybody's
a manufacturer by the parts and the guy
down the street it sounds like a leap a
is a much more centralized big
infrastructure kind of play than the
kind of things you've been describing
and that's what I meant by the
qualitative difference that doesn't seem
to fit the innovation pattern that you
were describing for that little phone on
the left I am seeing some things like
that I mean it's not you won't get
exactly analogous analogous to what you
see in the West obviously but you know
if you think of in a way sort of you
know the ecosystem as the Nespresso 4
hardware right I mean you have like
these facilities that can crank out like
things that are they're built in these
facilities in these factories but you
know I point is taking them in big do
you want to be able to create protected
ecosystems to do these big ecosystem
plays but I think in with the open
platforms because the adoption can be so
wide if you have sort of like this sort
of chicken-egg problem right for
likeness presses yeah again enough
coffee makers out there to make it
worthwhile stealing a supply train full
of coffee you know packets right and so
one way is we're going to protect the
insulin especially
so format we're gonna have the monopoly
in this we're going to build monetize to
get us all out there another one it's
like we're just going to like I'm going
to open the factory that makes capsules
or make them super cheap and everyone's
going to just use this capsule standard
and people just start building whatever
machines they want around this capsule
standard and then at the end a made the
best person win in my factory still make
a lot of money because I'm just cranking
out capsules at the end day I'm not as
high I'm not as valuable as Nespresso as
a brand but as an individual who's
interested in making factory those
capsules are making a lot of money at
the other day and so you don't quite get
like that brand power B I think you
still do some of these emergent
phenomenons of people if standardizing
and creating really big open platforms
that that a lot of people adopt and they
eventually get to a very high scale
everybody else thanks thank you
you